[Music]  bride-to-be Pippa Middleton appears to  be in tip-top shape Kate Middleton's  younger sis look stunning just weeks  before her wedding to James Matthews on  Thursday Pippa stepped out to attend the  PAR snow fundraiser at Hurlingham Club  in London dressed in a sleeveless Ihram  gown we can't help but stare at 33  year-old pimpest super tone arms in the  elegant ensemble it's clear the brunette  beauty has been dedicated to her fitness  routine as wonderful as ET previously  reported the socialite is putting in  extra time in the gym for her big day  our source says quote Pippa has been  stepping up her workouts she's been  working out about four or five times a  week and also has been doing Pilates I  think it's pretty impressive  [Music]